across the country ordinary Americans
from all walks of life are taking
whatever measures necessary to prepare
I'm preparing for a global earthquake an
electromagnetic pulse total economic
collapse terrorist attack catastrophic
tsunami and protect themselves pounce on
the prey
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it you are the most stubborn son of a
[ __ ] I've ever met in my life I swear
to God
next we go inside the lives of three
committed Preppers who have devised
extensive plans
it's beautiful since I've never had one
of these in my hand how do I aim this
gone to Great Lengths this is kind of a
high traffic area I think we should go
all the way vertical make it happen and
made huge personal sacrifices to ensure
their very survival either one of you
currently have any addictions
the experts will assess their preps to
see if they have what it takes
that's big to survive let's get
everything loaded it's just all the FED
over the top for me
[Music]
good morning
from the North End organic Nursery
you're tuned into an all-organic
gardening show that focuses on things
that you can do to be more
self-sufficient and being more dependent
on yourself and less dependent on the
world around you Lindsay is the co-host
of a radio show in Boise Idaho about
organic gardening and the back to the
land movement
today we're talking about food
preservation she and her husband Ray
Pride themselves on their urban
homesteading lifestyle
but Ray and Lindsey are in homesteading
just for nutritional or environmental
benefits
getting back to the land is their key to
survival if the World As We Know It Ends
we're preparing for the collapse of the
world's agricultural system
[Music]
what people don't realize is that a lot
of preppers are people like us where
everyday business owners we'd run very
normal lives my daughter goes to
gymnastics I take her to school every
day back in the day everybody was
prepared because they weren't so reliant
on other people to make sure their lives
work so Preppers today are really like
how our ancestors used to be smart
in 2012 the United States saw one of the
worst droughts since the 1930s dust bowl
and the hottest year ever recorded in
U.S history
nearly 80 percent of the country's
agricultural land was affected and
soybean and corn prices were at
record-breaking highs Ray and Lindsay
weren't surprised the collapse of the
world agricultural system is happening
now in the midwest we're having Mass
amounts of drought
climate change is changing the way that
farmers are able to reliably produce
their food people are severely detached
from the food system nobody knows how to
farm for the most part we've got a whole
bunch of City dwellers that are
dependent on a very small population of
farmers to keep them alive and if those
Farmers aren't able to deliver that food
to the table people are going to panic
and not be able to eat and feed their
families
if the world's agricultural system
collapses Lindsay's convinced only those
capable of producing their own food will
be able to survive
so she actively encourages her entire
Community to ready themselves through
her weekly call-in radio show on
sustainable living
it's three days worth of food is all we
have if all of a sudden we just stopped
supplying our supermarkets after that
you're on your own even if it's a small
disruption it could really turn into a
lot of chaos if you've got your own
garden and if you've got your own
ability to store and prepare food then
it's not going to affect you that much
while Lindsay concentrates on spreading
her message her husband Ray a former
Marine sees a darker potential
consequence of rampant food shortages I
don't think I'm paranoid
I just think I'm well informed and
prepared
my greatest fear will be the rioting the
lutein as we've seen in other disasters
across the country and across the world
the police will all go home the
firefighters will all go home there'll
be places of Blaze and before it ever
gets to that point my family and I will
bug out to our location to escape the
mobs of hungry people they fear Rey and
Lindsay plan to flee the city and head
off the grid to a secret location deep
in the Idaho mountains my Bug out
location is surrounded by National
Forest that has two streams on property
with a deep well
and has cabins that are made up in the
wood that we cut on our own land we have
security systems whether it be multiple
guns ammunition communication systems
whether it be VHF ham radio portable
walkie-talkies we have everything that
we need to survive Ray and Lindsay have
four years of food waiting for them at
their Bug out location
they keep more hidden in plain sight at
home
to many their backyard might look like
every other in the neighborhood but
every tree and shrub serves a proper
purpose we've basically turned our
entire landscape into something edible
veggies you know from zucchini and
tomatoes we have fruit trees of all
kinds and then we have grapes and
blackberries Lindsay and Ray's home only
has about four acres of land for growing
food so far they've crammed several
hundred edible plants into their
backyard
to preserve it and prepare it for
bugging out Lindsay cans as much of what
they grow as possible I do a lot of my
own canning so I can my own garden
vegetables I buy things in season and
can them dehydrate them do things
that'll make them last longer and these
are all things that'll sustain us
through you know several years like his
wife Ray believes most people won't be
prepared for Global agricultural
collapse
but he's concerned many in their area
will look to them for salvation I'm
constantly
told by my friends
whoever hits the fan
we're going to come looking for you
because we know that you're prepared
well
the hard truth is when it hits the fan
I'm not going to be able to support you
and your family
you need to have your own preparations
if any unwanted visitors refuse to take
no for an answer raise prepared to do
whatever it takes to defend what's his
there's nothing that I wouldn't do
protect my family in any kind of
Doomsday scenario
I could totally sleep tomorrow night
if I had to use Force deadly force
to prevent people from taking food out
of my family's mouth I have multiple
weapons with various calibers and as a
United States Marine I have absolutely
no doubt in my ability to hit what I am
firing upon as a marine Rey was taught
that teamwork is the key to successful
operations so he's been fortifying his
survival plan by recruiting other
able-bodied men and women to join his
team of Preppers I have a team of people
for my Bug out location because I can't
do everything myself tonight raise
gathered his team to interview two new
candidates the two new prospective
members to our team are currently
active duty United States military
personnel so it is imperative for
operational security of our Retreat that
we do not reveal their identity at this
time
we realize you guys have weapons and
guard Duty experience but do you have
any other relevant experience that you
can uh tell us about
I think the the both of us have
extremely high proficient uh outdoor
type skills so anything from actually
working with the crops to going out and
hunting together food we can definitely
bring to the table and also as long as I
can remember I've I've had a hand in
gardens and and fields around the Farms
so I feel really confident that I could
be a lot of help in food production for
the group growing up learning to hunt
and learning to care for crops I'm very
certain I'll be an asset to This Crew or
either one of you are currently on
medications have prescription eyeglasses
or have any addictions we have no
addictions no problems like that but I
do have prescription glasses okay I'd
like to be a part of Ray's crew because
uh I'd like to take care of my family if
in the event something were to happen
Rey's next step is to test his new
recruits to see what they're made of but
when he puts them in action and under
stress there's no telling what they may
do
[Music]
Lindsay and Ray fear that following a
global agricultural collapse Supermarket
shelves will be bare in just three days
but it's what happens on day four that
they fear most once people start to
realize that the food is not going to be
restocked on the shelves Panic will
start happening people will do what they
have to do to feed themselves which will
be including looting breaking into
people's houses becoming violent to
protect themselves in the four years
worth of food they've secured at their
Bug out location in the mountains of
Idaho Lindsay and Ray are looking to
recruit new members for their prepper
security Force I got two new prospective
members that I want to test to see if
they're meet the standards that what it
takes to be a part of this group
raise admissions test includes three
parts the interview teamwork drill and
response to a threatening situation
he'll be judging each potential member's
speed tactical skills and ability to
take orders and work with the group if
they disappoint him in any of these
respects they're out
all right you guys we need to bug out
let's get everything loaded
come on we might be running out of time
I don't want anybody to see this
foreign
loaded before anybody catches on that
we're loading up
we got our clothes we've got the
medicines first aid kits tools we've got
excess plants and seeds and radios bug
out bags vitamins Nursery items sewing
supplies towels books guns ammo if
anybody hears anything that we haven't
got packed let me know
someone help me lift this let's get this
thing closed up
you two get in the flatbed Lindsay and
Allison let's load up in the wagon
get in
with their full supply of preps loaded
within 10 minutes the Team Heads one
hour away to Ray and Lindsay's Bug out
location deep in the Idaho mountains for
the third part of their admissions test
the new recruits will be on their own
and Ray's last challenge for them is one
they won't see coming he's instructing
them to secure the area but he's not
telling them that somewhere between the
truck and the compound he's hidden in
occupying Force
I need you two to go up to the top of
the camp and make sure it's secure for
us to occupy
two-person patrols often move back to
back so that they can scan a full 360
Degrees around themselves
when breaching a building surprise and
speed are essential soldiers are taught
to dominate The Room by quickly moving
to positions of control that allow for
Clear shots
it's behind your back
clear
we got him
raised impressed that the candidates
didn't let their guard down or hesitate
when they encountered a threat as they
breached the door the two new members
have passed the test
welcome to the camp and the group
we're 100 committed to protecting what
is ours
and survive any disaster that may come
our way so once again welcome all right
guys good to have you people are under
the illusion that we have so much food
all around us and we're in this
wonderful Modern Age and all I can say
is that you're wrong there is so much
fragility in our system and it could
collapse at any time these things are
just time bombs waiting to happen and it
will happen at the end of the day the
question might be
when the big trucks stop rolling
is how much food are you holding
Ray and Lindsay the experts at Practical
Preppers have reviewed your preps your
four-year supply of food will give you a
huge advantage in trying to survive a
crisis however 50 gallons of stored
water would only last your survival
group less than a week you should be
storing more water we don't need to
store much water because we have surface
water at our Bug out location and a well
out of Bug out location your security
plan is strong but you should also
consider constructing a safe room so
that you can keep your supplies secured
at both our Bug out location and our
home location we have areas that we
would consider to be our safe rooms to
determine how long you could initially
survive a catastrophe Practical Preppers
has scored your preps in five categories
of 20 points each for a total possible
score of 100 your renewable food sources
are excellent 19 out of 20 points water
12 out of 20 points shelter 16 out of 20
points security 16 out of 20 points
working towards survival as a group
gives you 15 X Factor points your total
score is 78 out of 100 you have 15
months initial survival time that's a
pretty good score but whoever has graded
us hasn't really seen the extent of our
preparedness and if they did they would
say that it is in fact quite a bit more
extensive than what can be shown on TV
due to severe drought across the Midwest
the USDA warned that food costs could
continue to rise between three and four
percent in 2013. experts however do not
anticipate a catastrophic food shortage
to occur
s a bug out vehicle is a crucial part of
their plan for facing doomsday but for
Jim D his bug out vehicle is the whole
plan he doesn't intend to run away from
doomsday he intends to run it over in
his custom-built bug out truck that he
calls the behemoth
Jim D is a security consultant and proud
father living in the Orange County area
of Southern California a motorcycle
Enthusiast Jim used to spend his free
time working on his Harley-Davidson but
lately he's been under the hood of
something bigger
something matter
something he's felt to survive doomsday
that he calls
all right
the behemoth
I'm preparing for the destruction of the
power grid from a terrorist attack and
the social unrest that will follow
every year cyber attacks on their
computer systems that run the country's
infrastructure get stronger more
aggressive and hit more often
a government official has even warned of
a cyber Pearl Harbor that could take
down the country's Financial networks
government services and even the power
grid
Jim fears that this type of attack could
plunge the U.S into a new Dark Age we've
become completely dependent on the power
grid as soon as the power goes out the
stop lights don't work and the gas pumps
don't pump and the cash registers aren't
on and the electric doors don't open the
ATMs don't give any money there's no
power there's no Refrigeration there's
no there's no pumps to pump the water in
there's no pumps to pump the septic out
when people get hungry or thirsty they
start to act erratic and start to do
things that are not normal and when
people become desperate they do it
becomes even worse
my strategy is to be very mobile we
built a all-wheel drive 13-ton truck
that has a camper with 300 gallons of
fuel 150 gallons of water solar power
gas generators battery Banks armored
Command Center you name it it's designed
for extended deployment of multiple
people where you could sustain a lot of
lives for a long period of time
gyms spent close to three hundred
thousand dollars striving to turn a 1980
Chevy truck into his ultimate bug out
vehicle the engine was designed to be
able to to withstand a solar flare EMP
any electrical event because there's
nothing on it to fail
half inch thick armor plating
flame retardant military grade spray
paint
28 feet long 11 feet high and eight feet
wide Jim's mobile prepper Powerhouse
lives up to its name the behemoth
with more than 4 million miles of Road
in the U.S and no plan to stay put for
long Jim views life after doomsday as a
marathon not a Sprint and he's taken
steps to ensure the Behemoth will never
run out of gas we can run it on gasoline
or propane we've got 150 gallons of
propane 150 gallons of gas it's got
enough fuel to leave from Southern
California and make it to Nova Scotia or
Costa Rica or anywhere you know in
between so we can keep it moving for a
long long period of time
even with only 500 cubic feet of living
space Jim believes he's built the
Behemoth large enough for it to serve as
a rolling safe house for all his family
and friends
the Survivor truck can take 15 people
without being over capacity there's
nothing more valuable than my family to
me and whatever it takes to keep them
safe is what I have to do as a husband
and as a father it is my responsibility
I have a small group of people that
we've decided to rely on one another and
we're going to meet up and we're all
going to go together for Jim the
behemoth's most important cargo will be
his daughter Michelle but for Michelle
the idea of one day having to live in a
truck has just been one of her dad's
wacky ideas
holy water that's big until today come
on let's go I want to show you the
inside look at the Betty that mommy did
isn't that amazing yeah drums my bed
this one's your bed right here honey
it's actually bigger than your bed in
the house that bed if there's for mommy
and I it's a refrigerator and a stove
and all sorts of stuff we can stay in
this for a long time
[Music]
to be more than just a battle wagon he
wants it to be a second home
but he believes cyber terrorist attacks
could turn the U.S into a nation of
panicked violent mobs desperate to take
from him his fortress on Wheels so he
spent more than sixty thousand dollars
installing seven high-definition
surveillance cameras
Chad helped us he put all the cameras in
there and we're gonna go into the
command center and he's going to show
you how they work all right okay what
does all this stuff do well what we've
done Michelle is we've put cameras all
the way around the truck we've got a
camera in the front camera's on the
sides and cameras in the back that look
close to a couple hundred feet out being
able to see anybody that's in close
proximity to the truck we can see a full
180 degrees so you know if somebody was
outside that door let's show off what
this can do let's send your dad as far
away as we possibly can and see if we
can figure out what he's doing hey Jim
are you out there
I'm here all right we're gonna see if we
can find you
that looks like him how many fingers am
I holding up
two
oh Jim's confident his cameras can spot
a Potential Threat two miles away he
believes that whether or not his family
survives that threat could depend on how
he responds so tomorrow he's going to
put the Behemoth security systems and
his own weapons training do the test
Jim D fears cyber terrorists could
disable the power grid curling the U.S
into chaos and turning Americans into
violent desperate mobs
so to ensure he can escape hostile areas
with his family and friends he's built
the Ultimate Survivor truck
the behemoth
[Music]
Orange County California has more than a
dozen major highways but Jim fears he
could face massive gridlock in the Panic
following catastrophic cyber terrorist
attacks so since he can't predict which
Escape Route he might need to take he
has multiple Bug Out locations spread
all across the Southwest we've been
looking around trying to figure out
where to go based on Escape Routes
through you know throughout Southern
California
for the last two years he's been burying
Supply caches at Secret locations
between 2 and 100 miles from his home we
have multiple cash systems distributed
all over the country they're easy to get
to depending on whether we have to go
north south or east you have to have
something that's pre-staged if you just
have to pick up and go today Jim's
showing his prepping partner Ashley who
helped him design and build the Behemoth
what goes into assembling his caches
PVC pipes lined with a special material
that Jim says eliminates magnetic
signatures to Shield them from metal
detectors
we're going to start with the heavy
stuff first flashlight
take the bare necessities the weapons
ammunition flashlight kind of stuff you
know just enough to get by some food
bars just see rations and some water a
radio medical stuff you know just basic
stuff actually let's put that Glock in
there too
clear clear
we are good
Jim's taking the Behemoth out to bury a
new cache of supplies
with a clearance of almost two feet the
Behemoth can go where standard pickups
can't so Jim's heading for a remote
location deep in the mountains
but before he buries his cash his first
goal is to make the Behemoth disappear
the truck has a fully Deployable
thermoregulated camo net system that you
literally put it out and it just turns
you into a mound and you don't create a
heat signature Jim's camo netting is
designed to dissipate heat so that
anything underneath it remains hidden
from thermal imaging cameras and even
heat-seeking missiles
were essentially invisible to the naked
eye to night vision and thermal imaging
by the time Jim deploys the camo it's
almost too dark to see but that's part
of his plan the reason that we do this
at night obviously because it's much
more difficult to see people at long
range in the dark during the day you can
with a spotting scope you can see well
over a thousand yards there could be
people anywhere watching what you do Jim
berries is three foot long caches
vertically to reduce their surface area
at ground level making them harder to
find you buried in the ground and you
mark it with a GPS and you walk it off
and you map it
basically you have enough supplies to
sustain yourself for probably 60 days
with a family of four to six people just
in one cache my spot philosophy has
always been better to have it and not
need it than need it not have it you
know I want to be ready
in the event of a power grid shutdown
and the chaos that follows Jim worries
that the Behemoth might become an
enticing Target for desperate Marauders
so he and Ashley have been training to
defend the Behemoth from attackers
but shooting while on the move from the
custom sniper platform he built on the
roof requires a completely different set
of skills that gyms never practiced
until today
you have to compensate for the up and
down movement the left and right
movement of the sway factor in the
movement of the vehicle the distance of
the Target and the speed of the bullet
it's a lot to think about in a very very
short amount of time the challenges of
shooting while on the Move significantly
affect Jim's accuracy instead of kill
shots this time he hits mostly desert
sand
it's not the motion and the you know the
movement it's the up and down from the
from the uneven ground
it's brutal Jim believes that with
practice he and the Behemoth will be
able to take on any rioters and looters
should cyber terrorists succeed in
destroying American society in order to
be healthy and happy that you have to be
able to provide for yourself it feels
good to have a plan it feels good to
know that your family is going to be
safe
I have the the mental capacity I have
the desire to survive and I have a
spiritual center I know that I'm going
to be okay no matter what
gym
Experts of Practical Preppers have
assessed your preps you have an
impressive bug out vehicle with
High-Tech Communications but you need a
food resupply plan and reliable access
to water we have over or almost two
years worth of freeze-dried food we can
supplement that with hunting fishing and
growing food everywhere we go there's a
water source within 10 miles we'll be
fine
to determine how long you could
initially survive a catastrophe
Practical Preppers has scored your preps
in five categories of 20 points each for
a total possible score of 100
food 12 out of 20 points water 13 out of
20 points shelter 12 out of 20 points
security 15 out of 20 points your
special bug out vehicle will allow you
easier access to a safe location 13x
factor points overall you get a 65 out
of 100 you have 10 months initial
survival time well
I disagree we're gonna make it no matter
what I'm gonna last forever
Department of Homeland Security
currently considers cyber terrorism to
be a top security challenge
however power companies are devoting
tremendous resources to stopping cyber
threats and the electric grid has backup
systems that will allow power to be
restored quickly if the grid comes under
Cyber attack
Amanda and Scott bobbin recently bought
their dream home
with 51 rooms and breathtaking views it
seemed too good to be true but their new
house came with something unexpected
something
otherworldly
oh she's back again they say a voice
from the grave is telling them to become
Preppers
or die
laughs
on a Mountaintop in Waynesville North
Carolina the top 30 acres of land Amanda
and Scott bobbin live in a 51 room 8 500
square foot house we named The Heist
Paragon Jewel
which means
perfect
Jewel
and we believe actually that it is
Paradise
thank you
but it is a very unique and unusual
Heist
the things in this house are strange to
us
not things that we're used to everything
that we could possibly want in the in
the future if something would happen is
here already it's a prepper's paradise
safe haven for people to come and join
us after a comet will
hit the planet
now she's back again
one year ago the bobbins didn't give
much thought to Doomsday theories in
fact they'd never even heard of prepping
they were living in Florida when they
say they were warned about the end of
the world by a voice from Beyond which
would come to be known as Greta Amanda
and I lived in Florida and she received
a message of vibration whatever you'd
like to call it we often get them when
we sleep it comes through my
mind the message that I received was
it's time to leave Florida and that it
was very important for us to live at
three thousand feet or above
they say Greta urged them to move 3 000
feet above sea level so they could
survive a comet colliding with the Earth
destroying life across the globe
we sold the heists
and went to the mountains the bobbins
hunt for a new home LED them to the
Smoky Mountains of North Carolina and
the Paragon Jewel Amanda walked into the
door about 15 feet she turned around and
said to me this is where we're going to
live
we are located 3 000 feet above sea
level here it should be one of the
safest places on the entire planet and
that's why we've been brought here they
bought the Paragon Jewel and discovered
their new home came with two 5 000
gallon water tanks solar panels and even
a ham radio tower but the deeper they
delved into Paragon Jewels hidden
recesses
the more bizarre their new home seemed
we find huge quantities of supplies so
toilet paper gas masks there are things
for dehydrating instructions to create
Gardens that attract game animals they
had enough clothing upstairs in the
attic to clothe the hundred people
Amanda believes her mysterious voice is
Paragon Jewel's former owner a woman
named Greta who had already been dead
for two years
the bobbins believe Greta assembled all
this in the Hope survivors of the Comet
could find Safe Haven with her high in
the Smoky Mountains and now they believe
she wants Amanda and Scott to continue
her work Amanda and I are very confident
that we were guided to this house for a
specific purpose we believe the house
chose us to deal with what Greta had
started here we believe that as we go
down the road here Greta will instruct
this on what to do next
and that has been in contact with her
through channeling
Amanda says Greta makes her wishes known
by taking control of Amanda's body to
write out her instructions but Amanda
never knows when Greta is going to take
over
chicken I'm sorry that's not me either I
don't have any control over this
Grado has come through me and sent a
message
I bought what she expects us to do and
what she expects along the program today
so I have just written her words not my
words her
it's called automatic writing
I put so much love and care into making
it a safe haven
for people to come to when it will be
necessary you must carry on my work open
your doors to people who need you she's
back again
she's saying that Scott and I have to
continue that work working with her
hands being able to help a lot of people
because the situation is coming Amanda's
Sons Johnny and Christopher often visit
their mother from Ireland
but this is their first visit since
Amanda and Scott became Preppers and
they haven't yet been told the whole
story about Greta comets or prepping
Chris want to have a whack here
a guy came in uh something to do with
the solar panels
it is quite an unusual place and they've
done a lot of work getting it getting it
in shape because uh it requires a lot of
upkeep
the boys also don't know that if a comet
blasts Humanity to the brink of
Extinction their mother and Scott
planned to open Paragon Jewels doors to
every Survivor who comes to them seeking
help
and some of the first people they expect
to take in are their neighbors Scott and
mendov told us a little bit about this
house and the background of it and
they've talked a little bit about some
of the preparations they want to do to
have it better prepared their neighbors
aren't Preppers but they know Scott and
Amanda are starting to prep so they're
bringing Scott a present to help them on
their way
oh my goodness
we got you a nice brand new 12 gauge
pump action shotgun it'll take anything
from Big Game to small game and also
help you defend your house you
definitely need one wow it's unloaded
right now good looks beautiful even
camouflage don't point it at my mom
with her son still unaware of their new
prepping lifestyle Amanda realizes that
the gift of a firearm is something that
will require an explanation I watched
the Christopher's reaction when the gun
was handed over he seems a little
distressed I'll go and talk to him she
believes the time has come to tell them
about the comet so that the boys can
begin helping them prepare so guys we
need to talk to you too about something
and everybody else can just enjoy
themselves
but nothing can prepare them for how
Christopher reacts
for the last two months Scott and Amanda
bobbin have been prepping for a comment
to strike the Earth
but Amanda hasn't told her son
Christopher their plan yet
we are going to reveal to Christopher
that we have become Preppers and
see what his reaction is
we've moved into this house and after we
got here we started finding all these
things in the house that were very
unusual supplies supplies we were guided
here
and to continue the work of Greta she
expected a comment to come in
and hit the earth so we have
um
become Preppers
scientists would be able to predict
something like that
it's not just going to come up under the
blue
can't see anything happening I don't
know I just it's just all the FED over
the top right
isn't it better to be
prepared well I can't see
any reason why people were just almost
dedicate their lives to try to avoid
something what do you think Johnny
well
I think that was a good idea for in case
the storm or something
don't really understand it to be honest
I just don't know why why anything would
happen I don't think anything will
happen I hope you're right I really hope
you're right
but it doesn't hurt just to be prepared
a little
this has been a shock to him that
hopefully he will get some experience
and have
um a different View today Scots received
a gift his first security prep he's
ready to begin practicing defensive
prepping and hopes both boys will follow
his lead so this is our basic pump
action shotgun
our 12 gauge since I've never had one of
these in my hand how do I aim this sure
you're aiming straight down and you
always know what you're aiming at some
Preppers prefer the 12 gauge pump action
shotgun in part because they believe
just the sound of a shell being
chambered
can be intimidating enough to stop an
intruder the safety is on safety is off
right now oh the safety is off right now
after I shook it is that how you're
saying that
do you want to practice just
pulling it back and forward a couple of
times and I push this down you tell us
when you're ready I mean this is for
real this is for Real
okay so make sure you know where you're
aiming
nice shot that was brilliant that was
absolutely fabulous how did you do that
I thought you haven't done this before
fourteen-year-old Johnny is as eager as
his parents to prep for chaos following
a comet strike I think prepping's a good
idea if something bad happens you'll
have to be worried about glow nights
but 16 year old Christopher is not as
enthusiastic
he does not believe that self-reliance
is that important Chris you're going to
shoot why don't you give it a shot come
on I it was easy I'm not really
interested really oxidants could be
caused these Firearms are lethal I don't
really get too involved because I just
can't see anything happening
Christopher is extremely intelligent and
likes to use his brain more than his
Brawn he's talented but a little
reluctant to do certain things
Christopher won't shoot but Amanda and
Scott still want him to take an active
role in their prepping put your gloves
on we don't know I don't think anybody's
been in here in 25 years so they're
drafting him and Johnny to help them
inventory the supplies Greta left behind
in Paragon Jewel's shed let Mom keep the
official count and we'll just kind of go
around the room and see what we've got
in here
what's in this one over here oh we've
got at least 10 oats Amanda we've got
weight over here there's three there's
three more weeks what do you got down
below there wait see what's back in here
uh let's wait
Gretel Left Behind what could be
hundreds of gallons of wheat grains a
staple that humans have depended on for
thousands of years each five gallon
bucket was nitrogen sealed to remove any
Oxygen so it's protected from insects
and bacteria and is a longer shelf life
but Christopher doesn't believe any of
it will be necessary I really don't see
the point does
I mean if a comet or a meteor hits the
Earth and we cannot stay in the house
don't you think the land and everything
is just going to be destroyed so I think
what makes this place safe I think it
depends on where it hits at if it hits
on the other side of the world I don't
think anything's gonna happen so
I think I'm gonna leave I'm out of here
Christopher I'm not crap
I understand he doesn't think that we
are rational at all so maybe the next
time you'll come in Christopher's 16.
it doesn't matter what advice he gets
he's 16 years old somewhere along the
way he'll realize how important this is
Christopher and Johnny will soon be
returning home to Ireland Amanda and
Scott hope that with time both boys will
come to accept the prepper lifestyle but
for now getting ready for a potential
combat impact poses its own set of
challenges Amanda and I have been only
prepping about two months that's it we
are brand new Preppers we know we have a
lot of learning and to learn how to use
a lot of the things that have already
been prepared here for us there are
family members who are very skeptical of
what's going on but we are very
comfortable and confident that we'll be
prepared when the time comes
Scott and Amanda the experts Practical
Preppers have reviewed your Preps
you live in a geographically safe
location and of a good amount of
supplies you've taken the right step in
creating a network by opening your doors
to your neighbors however you need to do
more to secure your property consider a
security system cameras and defense
training I would agree with everything
that you have said and reported
to determine how long you could
initially survive a catastrophe
Practical Preppers has scored your preps
in five categories of 20 points each for
a total possible score of 100 food 16
out of 20 points water 17 out of 20
points
shelter 19 out of 20 points security 5
out of 20 points your large house and
ability to take in others will give you
strength in numbers this gives you eight
X Factor points
your total survival score is 65 out of
100 you have 10 months initial survival
time I believe we need to seriously
increase the defense and security aspect
um that seems to be our weakest point
has improved our gun awareness so
security system and they're collecting
rain water in our pool it is no
coincidence that we have fined each
other and I find ourselves here at
paragoncho I really believe our
adventure is only just beginning
both NASA and the United Nations have
departments that identify and catalog
potentially threatening comets and
asteroids of the more than 9 500
near-earth objects NASA has discovered
so far none is currently considered
likely to collide with Earth in the next
100 years
[Music]
thank you